hello everyone and thank you for such
wonderful comments in my giveaway video
there are already over 650 comments so I
guess it's gonna be quite a battle for
that championship set I didn't say in
the video but the tournament will be
held as usual and leeches and it doesn't
help to write more than one comment on
that video because the website I will be
using to choose winners they only choose
one comment per user so you know it's
kind of a kind of a protection from
spamming but that being said what is
this video about
seems like a grief should be defeated
world champion Magnus Carlsen in 7 moves
and yes in fact he has okay this is
chess960 but still you know a world
champion shouldn't lose games in 7 moves
although here you can see that Magnus
Carlsen has the black pieces but this is
for the second game I'm gonna show you
because you know I'm not gonna waste the
video for a game that lasted 7 moves
other than that
Tigran Petrosian game I did once because
you know that's a game everyone has to
know but in this game glitch 2 has the
black pieces and since we have a
chess960 setup I don't think there are
any openings here or if there are I'm
not aware of them so Carlsen plays efore
we have Knight to g6 by Greece Chuck f4
f5 e 5 now Knights to b6
we have d4 Bishop to c4 now attacking
Carlson school across since Queen on f1
Queen to f2 and here agree she plays d6
Carson replies with Knights the g3
developing his knight and here we have d
captures on e5 cross and replies with D
characters on e5 and here's the problem
here Grishka castled and yes you can
castle in chess960 the king just you
know changes positions with the rook so
I can't do this move to show you because
the interface does not allow me to
Castle now but the the cast link is made
the King comes here and the rook comes
here so imagine there's a rook now on
the e-file and Richard gave checked the
karlsen's Kingdom d1 and the King has
nowhere to go this Bishop is covering
- and in this position world champion
magnus carlsen resigned the game on move
seven I mean he can play Queen d2 or
queen d4 and give up the Queen but
that's just pointless so yeah that's
just something on the side I wanted to
show you as a bonus but now on to the
real game so this is the real game now
here
Carlson does have the black pieces and
the grease chip has the white pieces and
it was a very interesting match Carson
didn't cruised through the match like he
did with being Liron and Wesley so
although Carson did say that he was
pretty warmed up because he just played
the Wesley so a couple of days ago but
and the grace Chuck did have to warm up
a bit so in the first section in the
five-minute + 2 seconds increment
Carlsen won that event with 6 6 points
to two points in the three-minute +2
second increment he won with five and a
half to three and a half and somewhat
surprisingly grace Chuck won the bullet
section were the result of 5 to 4 and he
really really got on a roll but after
winning like three games in a row across
and then won a game and restrict simply
didn't have enough time to get back into
the game you know to get enough points
to equalize the match so ok a Crossin
did win this match I think it was a 15
and I have two ten and a half and a
great game a great match for cost and
the cost and it's now in the finals of
the speed chess championship and chess
calm and he's waiting
who will win them in the match between
Hikaru Nakamura and Sergey Karjakin
which will be played on 15th of December
and whoever wins I'm eager to see either
Nakamura in the final Sorkin in the
finals because you know Nakamura wants
the payback Carlsen for for losing to
Carson in in the last year's finals or
the speed chess championship and the car
can definitely you know looks forward to
every chance he has to beat up Carson
for from stopping him from becoming
world champion but okay there's some
background on the match this is one game
I chose this is a game from the 5+2
section and Greece chip has the white
pieces
he plays Knight to f3 the v g3 we have
the Kings Indian attack Bishop to g4 now
Bishop - G - C 6 and the Crystal Castles
the Knight to d7 d 3 and we have East 6e
for now Bishop to d6 h3 Bishop goes to
h5 of course you don't want to trade
Bishop for tonight.here
you capture Sun d5e chapter 75 and he
really is going to be one check ok 937
and we have a knife to h4 Crossing
castles and g4 and here already we have
a some tension going on on the board a
normal idea would be to continue the
game with Bishop to g6 and the white
would develop with Bishop to e3 and so
on and so on but Carson already here
decides to make things interesting
he please rook to e8 given up the bishop
on h5 and what's the idea here Bishop
Bishop captures of course the bishop G
captures on h5 and now Carson plays
Knight to c8 and already here is Chuck
can really take some initiative
but Girish should play the Queen to d1
and that's a pretty poor move allowing
the Queen to instantly recapture on h4
but this is something glistrup said
after the match that he couldn't really
get into the game that he really had to
play a couple games to warm up and that
he missed simple tactics because instead
of Queen to d1 here
he had the this Bishop to g5 move and
now if Carlsen captures the Queen anyone
restrict simply captures Queen and the
8th the queen of course cannot capture
bishop on g5 because Ganesha captures
rook on e8 with check and after
something like f6 and Bishop to e3 of
course you can save the peace pipe
because black does have d4 but after
night at five districts position would
have been would have been great
you're attacking the bishop on D sexy or
threatening something here on g7 h6
maybe is an idea this is a definitely a
good position for white but okay after
nine
c8 as a grease chip setting himself he
wasn't really into the game at this time
a queen to d1 was played in our Carson
simply capture screen captures on h4 and
this is a better position for for
Carlsen Queen to g4 Crowson does not
want to exchange Queens here we have h6
threatening Queen captures and g7 with
checkmate g6 c4 Knight to e5 now
attacking the Queen and the d3 pawn so
Queen Queen back to d1 d captures on c4
d captures on c4 and night to b6 Carson
isn't in a hurry to capture this c4 pawn
because he wants to improve the position
of his Knight and b6 and also he's
setting up a trap here if Christian
would protect this night for example the
pawn with something like b3 you know to
prepare Bishop b2 it looks very
promising for white
unfortunately he gets an IT captures on
c4 and after grease degree captures the
Bishop to e5 and you can't protect this
rook I mean you can but you have to put
something in front of it like give up
the knight or give up the bishop so
definitely a nice trick by Carlsen
so after I'd be six first Knight to c3
no not a long getting tricks and now of
course Carlson captures it nice to e4
attacking the bishop Bishop to e5 not
pressuring the b2 pawn and Bishop plays
Queen to f3 he doesn't mind that B to
pawn and definitely district has some
ideas of playing Knight to g5 and maybe
threatened that f7 pawn so Carlsen first
place f5 giving away tonight and I does
go to g5 but ok now the Queen isn't
attacking you have seven anymore
and here Carlsen probably probably
should have went for something like
Queen to e7 or Queen to f6 but he played
Bishop captures on b2 again with a with
an incorrect like a move but he manages
the trick grace rook here grace she
played Bishop to f4 Grishka could have
simply captured Bishop captures on b2
and after Queen captures night Angie
this is perfectly fine for black
something like Queen to c3
threatening checkmate on g7 White's
position is white position is good here
Queen captures on h6
Queen to h8 with check King to f7 Queen
f6 check King has to go back way nature
check this could have easily been a
drawn game if if district wanted to
maybe we should saw this and he didn't
want to draw me maybe he wanted to win
this who knows and if you don't capture
if you don't capture here with the Queen
if you capture Knight character Samba -
then Queen to c3 attacks the night and
also threatens checkmate this is not
winning for Greece trip so instead after
this bishop character some bit
aggressive played Bishop to f4 given up
the exchange cross and captured Bishop
captures on a one rook captures on a one
and Queen to f6 now attacking the rook
on a one rook the c1 we have worked to
DN by Carlsen now h4 r up to d4 we have
a queen to c3
now pinning the rook as the Queen and f6
is unprotected but cousin simply plays
rook to d1 would check you can't capture
the rook because you lose the Queen now
on c3 so after checking the King King
goes to h2 we have Queen captures on c3
rook captures and c3 Carlsen doesn't
mind exchanging pieces after all he's up
the exchange rocked the d4 now attacking
the bishop on f4 king g3 defending rook
eat the d8 doubling up on the D file but
also setting up another trap for Greece
truck and of course I mean not of course
but English took Falls for it he plays
Bishop to f1 but it doesn't really
matter what he plays a Carson would win
this position although you know you
never know in a fast game
Kiera Carlsen finishes the game with
rook captures on f4 and in this position
Alexander grisha resigned at the game
what would follow is if you capture the
rook you get Knight to d5
would check forking the king and the
rook and after King moves Knight
captures okay Bishop does capture the
knight would you check with after 95
Carson is up upon
the exchange in a completely winning
position so district decided it was it
was time to give up after row characters
on f4 but okay Richard himself said that
it had taken some time to get into the
match but he is kind of happy that he
won the bullet section at least but you
know he definitely put up much more
resistance than Wesley so or ding Liron
but I will put a link to the entire
article from chess comm so you know we
were welcome to read the entire article
and there are a couple of more games
analyzed it there and I will put a link
of my giveaway a video so if you haven't
entered the giveaway and you wish to win
a chess set or some some Amazon gift
cards you know feel free to check it out
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jeremy
Gunther for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usually project two of my previous
videos here things all for watching and
I will see you soon